do I talk to his father here why don't
you talk to his father I'm working can
you please go sit in your car you have
nothing to do with this father minor I'm
an attorney cuz he's a minor you need to
tell me is he going to be here I don't
need to tell you anything I'm going to
arrest you in a second if you don't get
in your car an attorney files suit
against a Rhode Island Police Department
after she says officers violated her
civil rights and assaulted her the
entire incident caught on body camera
video help help take it no you do not
touch me
oh my
God oh my God are you king me the
lawsuit stems from a February 9th
incident in South Kingstown Rhode Island
about 40 minutes south of Providence
body camera video shows the scene that
ultimately led up to Claire Hall's
arrest after she says she was acting as
a Good
Samaritan yeah the key stuck it's broken
are you going to well so do you think
he's going to be taken with the scene or
will he just are you I'm not no no I'm
on the pH my dad how how many cars are
involved right now not mine that's my
let's let's we need to get that off the
road all right can we get that into the
parking lot as shown in the video a
17-year-old boy had gotten into a car
crash according to court documents filed
by Hall and her husband the boy
apparently sustained a head injury in
the crash she says she offered to call
the boy's father from the scene I'm was
trying to tell his father so okay well
we're in the middle of the highway so
all right can you can you move your car
please throughout the video Hall can be
seen approaching two officers asking for
more information to give the boy's
father my man is your car drivable yes
all right we're going to get it off to
the side of the road all right all I'm
saying is I can leave I just want to
tell his father you don't have to leave
just move your car I'm just want are you
okay yeah I'm okay let's have a seat
right over
here is that your mom no But as time
ticks on the officers become
increasingly upset with Hall's comments
one officer can be heard yelling at Hall
when she asks him to speak with the
boy's father after that he threatens to
arrest her talk here why don't you talk
to I'm working can you please go sit in
your car you have nothing to do with
this father minor I'm an attorney CU
he's a minor you need to tell me is he
going to be here I don't need to tell
you anything I'm going to arrest you in
a second if you don't get in your car
soon the officers tell Hall she's
interfering with an ongoing
investigation still she refuses to leave
the area and get into her vehicle you
understand me I'm not kidding you you
are kid you are impeding an
investigation right now and you're
really bothering me go sit in your car I
will talk to him in a minute get in your
car now seconds later a struggle breaks
out as First Responders take call into
custody c c take it no you do not touch
me oh my God doing oh my God are you
kiding me knock it off you will knock it
off you get your hands off me right now
get your
hands tell to get your hands off I do
tell to get his hands off me oh my God
are you stop no I not starting as this
continues Hall can be heard calling for
the officers to turn on their body
cameras are
you
right guys are you you record this it's
recording record I'm wearing a body
record she then screams asking officers
why she's being arrested I understand
but why am I under a r because you
weren't listening to anything we were
saying oh my God you're not
listen oh my God I will can you please
can you please take a breather no take a
breather the struggle continues as
officers suggest Hall is resisting
arrest right now not you at all I just
move my heart so it doesn't hurt I how
about you stop resisting and you let us
put you in hand my shoulder is
dislocated and you're making it work as
the heated exchange goes on Hall yells
at officers saying she was just acting
as a Good Samaritan I've want in custody
dis resisting God oh my God you got to
be kidding me care you got to be kidding
me stop no stop talking no no this this
is so R I cannot even believe this oh my
god let's go put her in my car I just
wanted to know I could tell his father
if he's going to the hospital I'm not
even involved in this I can't believe
this that was our point the whole time I
cannot believe this that was our point
the whole time you are not involved you
are not involved I'm a Good Sam
instructed you to do something a Good
Sam refused to do it I'm a Good
Samaritan who stopped to help a kid and
this what happen Okay stop growing I'll
get up with my own you're oh my God stop
it I want my phone it's over there what
am I doing he's pulling my he's pulling
my hey stop get my shoe please get my
shoe get get my oh my God oh my God oh
my God I never I cannot even believe
this the yelling continues as Hall says
officers are beating her before she
threatens a lawsuit man is beating out
of me holy shit yes he is oh my
God oh my God this is the crazy I've
never stop pushing me please I will
walk are you kidding
me you are you guys don't know how much
trouble you I'm going to see you both
first s right
now you're in so much trouble I can't
even I can't even tell tell you oh my
God this is the craziest thing I've ever
in my entire I'm not going relax I am so
I can't help I I don't have to you guys
where do you where do you get
thiso this
is I need my phone it's on the ground
over there grab it I will grab it oh my
husband he's also an attorney go ahead
get this is so bad yeah I can't even
phone right here oh surprise later
another officer arrives to the scene he
discusses where the keys to Hall's
vehicle may be find her key but the car
started up so it's in there somewhere
Keys
probably would it start up from like
yeah all right if the car's on and
running with a push to start the car's
on and running it will run as long as
the keys in a certain distance this is
probably a certain distance now you you
drive you take a key off of her her yeah
when you when you I didn't either did
you put a car gra her pocket book and
everything she didn't she she was just
out of the car all we have is her cell
phone a shoe glasses glasses that's it
the the keys either on her person most
likely or the keys in her pocketbook
does it say uh he not a vehicle no cuz
it started right up wait so the key is
in the car yeah I just couldn't find it
though
oh probably holder all right you want me
to move his Volvo he can't move it it
won't off I would have moved it why
don't you bring start before why don't
you bring her
back get her out of here get her I'm
assuming that she's Anning she's got get
her she C and
then
that yeah I heard you guys I heard you
guys say one and clust I'm like here we
go officers then discussed the keys with
Hall before the body camera recording
concludes do you have your car key on
you where in your car is
it okay all right I'll T up driver
now
my little black pouch she said in her
car that work you can get her on she
calm down a little bit now she better
than she was I wonder how she'll be in
the block but somebody will be at the
station to help me yeah I'll
back M I think Hall was later charged
with obstructing an officer resisting
arrest and disorderly conduct she since
filed suit against the South Kingstown
Police Department through the town
manager police chief and two of the
officers involved on the scene she's
alleging assault battery civil rights
violations police brutality and
excessive force and intentional
infliction of emotional distress we
reached out to the South kingtown Police
Department for more information about
this pending lawsuit they replied in
part quote clear Hall's arrest was as a
result of her interference with officers
at an active crash scene reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie